the rising tensions with North Korea
have put a new spotlight on Asia one big
issue is how China's growing ambition
and military power could impact US
influence in the region East Asia expert
Richard McGregor explores the complex
dynamics in a new book it is called
Asia's reckoning the award-winning
author and former financial time Beijing
bureau chief says regions complicated
history she has light on many of today's
diplomatic challenges McGregor writes as
its power has grown China has begun
building a new regional order with
Beijing at the center in place of
Washington the battle lines are clear
Richard good morning the morning you
suggest that in the region Beijing says
the United States is there by choice it
chooses to be there while China is there
by geographical reality meaning that's
how they see their role as superior to
the u.s. role well their geopolitical
fact in Asia the u.s. as you say is
there by choice and I think China wants
to make the cost for the u.s. to be
there go up and up slowly not rapidly
they don't want the u.s. to leave
quickly but over time China naturally
wants to dominate Asia it wants to be
the hegemonic power if you like and
ultimately replace the US but not in a
way that we might sort of see happening
at the moment with the destabilization
edge the question is anything the United
States can do to stop that well I think
over time the US would have to share
power I mean not with you know if the
Chinese economy collapsed or something
like that if there was a terrible
internal upheaval inside China that
would change the equation but over time
there's not much the US can do to
maintain that the role it's had for the
past 70 years one of the one of the main
factors if not the main factor is the
relationship between China and Japan
which there's the the trade thrives
between the two countries economically
speaking but politically it's been tense
for years and since World War two or
before that how does the relationship
between China and Japan play into the
future and and how does it affect the
u.s. well in the big pitch if you think
about it East Asia's you know I've been
had a fantastic economic growth in the
last 70 years it's been an economic
success it's been a political failure
the Korean Civil War has never been
solved the Chinese civil wars never been
solved China and Japan have worse
relations now than they've had for
decades and if China and Japan have
conflict that automatically means that
the u.s. is in there as well because the
u.s. is japan's treaty allied sworn to
defend it and if they come to blows
that's the entire global economy goes
through these three countries and that's
a big deal you know you call it the
geopolitical version of Reservoir Dogs
which i think is a very interesting
visual all pointing guns at each other
and all blaming each other yeah I mean
they've all in different ways dependent
on each other threatening each other
that sounds odd to trade by each other
and trade with each other they're all
interdependent in a highly sort of
valuable way in many respects but also
violets increasingly volatile fashion
speaking of an issue we've been talking
about this morning and recently which is
North Korea and China's influence are
there circumstances in which China might
say to North Korea you've got to stop
this and we are part of the US effort to
get you stop it well the problem is
they've kind of been saying that for a
long time and North Korea's they're not
doing it no they haven't done it the
problem with China is China has enormous
economic leverage over North Korea but
it's the kind of leverage if they used
could come back against them you know if
North Korea collapsed if North Korea
fell into the arms of South Korea then
China would have a US ally on its border
and China's made the choice so far no
matter how crazy North Korea has got you
know keeping them there is better than
having them in you know as part of u.s.
there's some people in the Trump
administration who believe that we ought
to declare and these are nationalist
economic war against China because of
the economic war that they have declared
against us in terms of what they do with
respect to tech companies and other
people to participate in the Chinese
economy well the US should take on China
on a number of fronts particularly on
the issue of technology and technology
transfer but the idea of economic war is
something altogether
beyond that and you know if mister you
know I think there's a lot to say from
mr. Trump putting China a little bit
off-balance as he did at the start of
his administration but if mr. Trump is
putting his own White House off balance
is putting the us off balance at the
same time he can't do it much with China
with China you need a long-term 3/4
decade-long strategy to sort of push
back against their own economic
nationalism and that's what the US does
not have at the moment they do practice
you cannot make nationalism absolutely
well he appeared to cultivate a
relationship in the beginning when he
invited President Xi Jingping to visit
him in mar-a-lago and then it seemed to
have taken a turn well he's taken many
turns he's taken many turns on North
Korea is taking many turns on China he
said Jinping was a terrific guy well he
may be a terrific guys for his family
but that's not quite the point really ok
so we've got this Congress coming up I
mean how crucial is it and what will it
decide for China well this is this will
CC Jinping barring any major shot
consolidate his power perhaps
consolidate it for another not just five
years ten years
and it will I guess in you know embolden
him further internationally
you know once he's in complete charge of
the Politburo and the Politburo Standing
Committee so in other words he could see
China settled down a little bit Jinping
the most consequential Chinese leader
since well dunx helping without a doubt
Richard McGregor thank you very much
thank you